A man carrying a Palestinian flag was
attacked and had the flag torn away from
him during Israeli protests against
legal reform plans it's moments like
this that Palestinians say exposes the
LIE of Israel's system it's okay for
Israelis to protest freely but for
Palestinians it's a very different
matter they get military occupation
daily killings and systematic Force
displacement some Palestinians are
worried that they are about to pay a
price for Israel's crisis over illegal
reforms in the past Israel has been
accused of using Palestinians as
scapegoats to distract from its own
internal problems including by launching
Wars on the besieged Gaza Strip now one
of the top officials in Israel's
far-right government it's Ahmad benevir
says he has one agreement for the
creation of a national guard under his
Direct Control the plan has reportedly
been in place since last year but now
tanikvir has released a signed letter
agreement with prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu for the creation of such a
force bengvir is an illegal settler
living in the occupied house Indian West
Bank who regularly incites violence
against Palestinians and who has a
criminal conviction for racist
incitement one Palestinian member of the
Israeli knesset likened the situation to
giving a terrorist a private Army
there's also concern that Israeli
settlers will be emboldened by this
extra power for Benfield attacks by
settlers on Palestinians have been
happening on a near daily basis and
there were more on Monday nights after
bunny Beer's latest announcements and in
addition to the government announcing
plans for new illegal settlements the
Israeli Army has carried out near daily
deadly raids on Palestinians and
occupied West Bank
so while Israelis may be concerned about
their so-called democratic system the
concern for millions of Palestinians
living under military occupation is an
increase in systematic Israeli violence
against them
[Music]